a hybrid girl and others like her are
being held at a testing center as the
areas overrun by hundreds of hungry
zombies melanie escapes with a teacher
and helps guide humanity's survival
today on cinema recap i'll show you the
girl with all the gifts the film begins
with a girl named melanie who's locked
in a cell while some soldiers are
outside yelling to kids to get ready
because they're going for them the girl
quickly puts on her clothes a red suit
and sits in a wheelchair while some
soldiers open the door of her cell
and melanie says hi kindly the soldiers
secure to the chair and take her to
where the other children are gathering
them in a room separated by numbers
marked on the floor when everyone is in
that room we see that a teacher arrives
who begins to teach the children things
as if they were at school
and we see that melody stands out from
the others later all the children return
to their cells and we see how the girl
despite the circumstances kindly says
goodbye to the soldiers wishing them a
nice day they give the girl food and we
can see that they've brought worms on
her plate because that's the food they
give to all the children later a female
soldier named caldwell the doctor in the
area begins to ask questions of melanie
like a random number from 1 to 20. the
girl chooses thirteen the next day the
soldiers arrive following their daily
routine which is to take the children of
the room where the teacher is but
melodies notices that one of the
children is missing and she can also see
that it was the one with number thirteen
then after attaching small tables to
their chairs the teacher asked them to
write a story
after a while she asked the volunteer to
read what he or she wrote and our
protagonist quickly raises her hand the
girl reads it aloud telling a story
about a girl who was very happy with her
mother
the story is so good that the teacher
even shed some tears when the girl sees
the teacher with tears in her eyes she
thinks she did something wrong and
apologizes
the teacher walks over still moved by
the story and strokes melanie's hair
then a very angry soldier comes in and
scolds the teacher since she should not
get so close to the children
to demonstrate why she shouldn't do that
the soldier approaches and offers an arm
to a child once the child feels the
man's hand nearby he begins to suffer a
change his zombie side awakens and he
wants to go after the soldier's arm to
eat him and this is because all those
children are kind of hybrid between
human and zombie and that's why they
have them locked up we can also see that
other children in the room smell the
scent of the soldier so they start
throwing bites into the air while the
soldier explains to the doctor that a
special cream must be used to disguise
their smell
but that you still don't have to get so
close then they return all the children
of the cells melanie sees the soldier
who scolded the teacher and tells her
that he wishes her harm
so the man tells the other classmates to
leave her tied to his chair as
punishment after a while we see the
teacher walk through the corridor where
she notices the melanie is still tied to
her chair
she attempts to untire but the girl
feels her smell and begins to transform
into her zombie side so she tells her
teacher that she better go away when the
teacher hears the upset girl she quickly
leaves the cell apologizing to melanie
for what happened
at the same time she reapplies the cream
to her face and hands the next day dr
caldwell arrives who notices what was
left of the teacher's cream on the floor
and asked melanie to give her a random
number from one to twenty
the girl chooses four the doctor gets
surprised and asks she's sure since
melanie is in cell number four the next
day we see how the soldiers do their
routine of taking the children to class
and melanie gets ready then the girl
notices that they take all the children
but her after a while she's taken to the
outside finding out that the world is
infested with zombies they take the girl
to where the doctor is already waiting
for her
there they inject with a sedative
demobilizer and put her on a stretcher
since the doctor uses the children to
try and find a cure against a zombie
virus she prepares a scalpel but shortly
before she begins the teacher arrives
threatening the doctor and her assistant
not to hurt melanie caldwell asks the
woman to calm down the teacher lets her
guard down the doctor sprays her with
pepper spray and calls the guards to
take her away
then they want to continue with the
procedure but the alarm sounds
indicating that the zombies have entered
the military zone one of the undead gets
through a window trapping the doctor's
assistant and biting her caldwell saves
her but shortly after the bitten woman
turns into a zombie that zombie slowly
approaches melanie the girl gets scared
but she realizes the undead is not doing
anything to her
since she also has zombie cells in her
body then the girl takes a scalpel and
manages to get loose for her bonds she
escapes from the place and notices that
outside everything is a disaster
then she sees the guards who are
carrying the teacher and sees they've
beaten her up so melody goes for them
and bites them on the neck later the
girl begins to lie down as the sedative
begins to take effect
the teacher carries her in her arms and
wants to escape although she's
surrounded by zombies a truck of
soldiers arrives to save them
and she boards with melody in her arms
later they escape from the place while
we find out that the doctor was the one
who saved them
later the soldiers driving the vehicle
realized that melanie is in the back and
they want to kill her but the teacher
opens the door for her to escape
although she stays close by since she
doesn't know how to be alone they decide
that they'll go to a safer place
and since melanie could have the cure in
her cells they also carry her but
wearing a special mask then the truck
breaks down so they have to continue on
foot
but we notice how one of the soldiers
still mistrusts melanie a lot
later on their way they see that there
are many zombies where they'll pass
but because they don't have human beings
nearby to eat they're just standing
still they decide to go through since
they have cream on and they must be safe
but the soldier warns them to go very
slowly since sudden movements or noise
could wake the zombies up they pass
among the undead while the soldier
guides them then they notice how a
zombie woman carries a stroller the
doctor lifts a blanket that is in the
baby carriage and freaks out since there
was a rat rather than a baby then the
zombies wake up but the soldier begins
to shoot them and they take refuge in an
abandoned building melody and the doctor
wait while the others disperse to secure
the building the girl asks what's going
on so caldwell explains that many years
ago they found it apart from the zombies
there were also half undead and half
human hybrids she explains that when a
pregnant woman becomes a zombie her baby
lives but with zombie jeans
she also tells her that this is why she
is trying to find the cure through
children like her
in order to save humanity the next day
since they're surrounded by zombies the
girl tells them that she can go out to
create a distraction
so she changes her clothes and goes out
passing among the zombies since they do
not do anything to her she finds a cat
and ends up eating it then she finds a
dog and takes it so the zombies would
follow her to eat it and therefore the
others can lead safely as they go on
their way they notice how some zombies
died and sprouts came out of their
bodies
later they came across a large structure
made of pure zombies that turned into
branches
and created a large mushroom
so the doctor explains that this is the
next stage of the life of zombies she
also explains that from that gigantic
zombie mushroom
some buds come out which could end
humanity since they would release a
spore into the air that will turn all
who breathe it into the undead later
they find some armored army trucks which
the doctor identifies as mobile
laboratories
they enter and use the radio to
communicate but receive no answer later
still one of the soldiers goes out to
look for food and the girl also asks
them to let her out since she feels
hungry and doesn't want to cause an
accident inside
so she goes out and feeds on a pigeon
then the girl hears noises and when she
gets closer she sees that there are more
children like her but she notices that
they only want to kill to survive and of
course they're more intelligent than
ordinary zombies
so she returns and warns the others they
come to the rescue of the soldier who
went out to look for food but the
children went ahead and found him first
so they ate him before they arrived they
emerged from the place where the
soldier's body was found but the zombie
children were waiting for them outside
they see that there are too many of them
so melanie fights with the leader of the
children beating him in battle so the
others will fear her
they return to the truck where the
doctor puts them all to sleep with the
gas
in order to be able to do tests with
melanie and try and find the cure
but the girl only pretends to be asleep
to mislead the woman and she waits until
she is distracted to surprise her then
the doctor tries to convince her to
sacrifice herself to save humanity the
girl refuses to cooperate since she'll
have to die for that and she also
doesn't trust caldwell so she runs away
later caldwell goes out to look for her
but she runs into the zombie children
who ear alive
at the same time melanie sets fire the
gigantic mushroom made by the zombies
behind her comes the soldier who went
out to look for but when he breathes the
smoke from the mushroom he turns into a
zombie then melanie goes back to the
teacher who's the only survivor since
she's safe inside the trucks and the
smoke doesn't reach her some time passes
and we see how the teacher and melanie
have created a kind of school to educate
the zombie children since they will be
the future of humanity the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to get into receiving
the recaps of the best horror movies
thanks for watching